there's been a race to make an electric
car that can go 200 miles on a single
charge and costs under $30,000 well it's
finally here and it's not a Tesla
[Music]
the 2017 Chevrolet bolt rolls into
dealerships this month almost a year
before Tesla promises to deliver on the
200-mile $30,000 equation when our
deliveries well there next year
I do feel fairly confident that we'll be
thank you
that's right Silicon Valley's darling
car maker just got whooped at its own
game by stodgy old GM in the old world
home of the automobile Detroit
[Music]
in truth it wasn't a fair race GM
already had a big factory just north of
Detroit full of 1500 workers capable of
putting out more than 300 finished cars
a day what they've delivered is a pretty
remarkable machine so this car will go
from zero to 60 in less than six and a
half seconds it has a top speed of about
95 miles an hour with a big 10.2 inch
touchscreen here it shows all the
diagnostics of the car there's an 8 inch
digital instrument cluster here so you
can always get a sense how many miles
left till your battery's dead it's
really spot-on
and it rides beautifully
but the bolt is not however is beautiful
pragmatic is probably the best word
Chevy designers wanted to sell the
vehicle as a crossover SUV with lots of
headroom and the driver's seat well
above the road the result is a stubby
little pot of a machine accentuated by a
bunch of busy design details Chevy did
need to make some choices to keep costs
down inside the bolt is full of cheap
plastic and rubber and if you want to
charge it in less than eight hours you
have to pay an extra seven hundred and
fifty dollars for a fast charging port
looks aside there's really no reason to
not buy this car it's sure to win some
would be Tesla buyers who don't run away
the market for a long range low-cost
electric car won't be winner-take-all
but it is for the next year or so
because there's nothing on the road
right now quite like the Chevy Volt
[Music]